Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. Here is a caller
who I think believes I really did lose my YouTube
channel. I don't even know what that would mean,
but this caller seems to believe I lost my YouTube
channel and mentions not Satan but saint and
saint. And I've never heard this before. Listen.
Speaker 2: Hey, where you go? I mean, on YouTube.
I've seen that Ring of Fire, Eddie. He got how
to use your Pacman strap on YouTube. What do.
Speaker 1: You think? I think what the caller
means is Farren filled in for me last week.
Speaker 2: Not even on there. Y'all going to have
a ring of fire? It's called the Lake of Fire.
And I hope you like swimming. Washington Saint.
Speaker 1: Okay.
I did not actually get kicked off of YouTube. It
was an April Fool's gag on April 1st weeks ago.
Everything's fine. And I don't know what to do
about Saint Anne. But I will certainly look into
it. We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else.
Speaker 5: That makes money to fund themselves is.
Speaker 1: Bad. I'm going to tell you all about my
trip last week. Got recognized by some interesting
folks over in the U.K., had a confrontation with a
customs officer at JFK Airport on my way back. So
many stories, some of which maybe are remotely
interesting to you. On today's bonus show,
producer Pat will join me. So much to discuss.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com. Get instant
access to the bonus show and use the you can use
the coupon code indicted or indicated whichever
spelling you prefer indicted or indicated.
Both get you a discount at join pacman dot com.